elle vient elle aussi de prendre pour la
première fois dans l'histoire de son
pays et même de son continent les
commandes d'un état ellen johnson
sirleaf est officiellement élue
présidente du libéria avec près de 60%
des suffrages c'est la première fois
qu'une femme occupe de telles fonctions
en afrique chien colombani ellen johnson
sirleaf a des airs de vieille dame
tranquille mais il ne faut pas s'y
tromper au liberia on la surnomme la
dame de fer est aujourd'hui son but est
atteint
c'est la première présidente du liberia
la première femme à accéder à la
fonction suprême sur le continent
africain
je suis très heureuse et je remercie le
peuple libérien
je trouve ça très stimulant mais je
reste humble devant lyon au stage qui
nous attend économiste diplômé de
harvard ancien cadre à la banque
mondiale
ellen johnson sirleaf aura pour mission
de redresser le pays
exemple après 14 années de guerre civile
il n'ya toujours ni eau ni électricité
dans la capitale il faudra aussi
s'occuper des cent mille enfants soldats
qui errent encore dans tout le pays
la première chose à faire c'est de
consolider la paix et d'inciter des
milliers et des milliers de jeunes ex
combattants et les teams tous éprouvé
par la guerre
à suivre des programmes de formation et
à s'engager dans des activités
productives la proclamation officielle
des résultats intervient trois semaines
après les élections car son adversaire
malheureux l'ex-star du football george
weah conteste l'issue du scrutin
la nouvelle présidente hu a proposé
d'entrer au gouvernement
mais les partisans de wade n'ont pas
hésité la semaine dernière à descendre
dans la rue
quatorze mille casques bleus de l'onu
kadri le
la situation peut être explosif ellen
johnson sirleaf garde beaucoup d'ennemis
car on lui reproche ses engagements
passés auprès de l'ex dictateur charles
taylor